[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka bro katan
because i'm i'm your bro and this
episode we have a lot to talk about
episode three of the mandalorian has
some major tie-ins to the clone wars
and it's packed with easter eggs from
beginning to end
the entry picks up almost immediately
after the events of the last one
with mando and kermit the frog lady
traveling to trask
with the last of the latter's species
here he comes face to face with sasha
banks's character
whose true identity we discover is
koshka reeves
when the trailer first dropped many
people thought it was rosario dawson
playing ahsoka
i thought that it could be sabine wren
but in the end we discover that it's
actually a mandalorian warrior in league
with bokutan
we watch as the razor drifts towards
trask and this shot was actually used as
the opening for the trailer for season
2.
due to it being worse for wear its
atmospheric protection
simply isn't there and you may remember
that something similar to this happened
at the beginning of revenge of the sith
trask is in a boo-like location covered
almost completely in water
and because of this the locals of it
tend to be based around the element
this is why the frog lady wanted a
journey here as
like she said it would be very
hospitable for her family
after crash landing in the bay mando
asks a local mon calamari mechanic to
help fix the ship
the mon calamari are actually renowned
for their ability to build ships
and ironically they're also known as
being very poor
sailors the amphibious species however
can swim
very well underwater and even exist
amongst it for long periods of time
notable ones include admiral akbar who
i'm sure you know from the original
trilogy
namely return of the jedi maybe he
should have told mando that it's a
trap eh when he gets tricked but but he
didn't so i don't really like the guy
now we also see a crane lift the ship
out of the water that appears to have
legs similar to an 8080
the place is absolutely filled with
easter eggs and not only does the frog
lady get reunited with her husband
we also catch a glimpse at sasha banks's
character who it seems is spying on
mando
this explains how the group later
arrived to save him from the
backstabbing quarren
that promised to take him to some
mandalorians i suppose
they do take him to some in a way and
the quorum are a species that come
directly from the planet deck which is
also the home of the mon calamari
over the centuries they've kept up a
pretty tense relationship with the other
indigenous species
but on trask at the very least it seems
like they and the mon calamari get along
a small squid-like creature is given to
baby yoda as food
and this also tries to suck his face off
i think this might be building upon the
alien reference last week
with this thing becoming almost like a
facehugger manu gets a ship with some
quarren sailors
but they end up ambushing him because
they want the best car armor he
possesses
as we learned in the first episode of
this season this metal has become
more and more scarce throughout the
galaxy and it's likely that they could
live comfortably for the rest of their
lives if they manage to attain it
they shove baby yoda into the feeding
pit of a giant eel-like monster
and mando dives in after the child he
becomes trapped and is only saved by the
arrival of three mandalorians
led by none other than boca tan this
ties back to the title the heiress
and beau is actually in line for the
throne of mandalore
beau is played by katie sakhoff who also
voiced her in the show
and she looks incredible in the costume
balkatan was originally a massive part
of the clone wars series
and throughout she went head-to-head
with several imperial forces and sith
lords
when it was revealed at the end of
season 1 that moff gideon had the
darksaber
many assumed that she had died so i was
so glad to see her back in this series
the darksaber is basically the
ceremonial weapon of mandalore
and whoever wields there is seen as the
leader of the mandalorians
before gideon beau was the last person
that we know wielded it
and many thought that she would part
with her life before handing it over
it seems that the moth managed to take
it from her and the episode is very much
about her learning of his location
in an attempt to get it back the action
scene of them arriving is incredible
and it was difficult not to completely
fanboy over them showing up to save
mando's life
now a big point of contention in the
show is that this group of mandalorians
removed their helmets it's been hammered
home throughout the series that
mandalorians should not do this
and it comes as a great surprise to
mando when they do
the whole helmet thing has been highly
contested and there has been a lot of
back and forth in the star wars
community
over which way is right boba rates man
know for being part of the watch
who are occult of religious zealots that
broke away from mandalorian society
as they sought to re-establish the
ancient way thus
mando is mocked a bit by the other
mandalorians
and now it turns out that that there is
two ways
hey now i'm glad that they addressed
that here and who knows
going forward mando might actually start
taking his helmet off a bit more
because hey pedro pascal looks glorious
bro
now the male mandalorian that is with
them i know his face
i just can't put my finger on who it is
and i've spent ages googling british
actors to find out who's playing him
i couldn't but if there's one thing i
know it's that my audience
is much smarter than me and one of you
will write the guy's name in the
comments below
and i'll be like ah it is it is john
johnson
anyway they blow the ship amanda returns
to the bay where he's ambushed by more
quarans who want revenge for the attack
the mandalorians arrive again and state
that trask is a black market planet
that is dealing in weapons which they
wish to take upon gaining these they'll
be able to reclaim mandalore
and return order to the planet manu kind
of scoffs at this
as he states that the empire ravaged it
to the point that it was inhospitable
but beau says that this is propaganda
that's used to divide them
mando stays strong in his mission to
return baby yoda to the jedi
and they state they'll tell him where
one is in exchange for helping out on
their job
mano leaves the child with the frog
family which i i wouldn't do
i just wouldn't do because i don't like
how he's looking at that kid
he's a maniac anyway cue a big action
scene in which they storm an imperial
freighter
which is commanded by titus wellevere
you may know him for playing the man in
black and lost
and i kind of wish that he got a bit
more of a role as he's an awesome actor
you can also hear the alarm sound that
was used on the death star
and the elevator 2 takes the designs of
one scene on that
the show really goes all out in the
final 15 minutes
and it feels like one of the best action
scenes in its history
i love how season two has really ramped
up the action
and after i was left feeling a bit
disappointed by last week's entry
i have to say this easily won me back
round mano and co
move through the ship one by one wiping
out the imperial officers and
stormtroopers
and they send a vast majority of them
out through an airlock
the ship is forced to signal help from
moff gideon and he hasn't really got
any words of encouragement for them it
was awesome seeing
giancarlo esposito back and as we know
he possesses the darksaber
bo kitan has been hunting him in order
to get it back and i love how their
rivalry is slowly being set up here
as we know he's also after the child and
we will likely see mando teaming up with
bo once more
in order to stop the villain the moth
sends the ship off on a kamikaze mission
amanda almost has to do one of his own
as he rushes stormtroopers with thermal
detonators
bo and cole managed to stop the ship
from crashing and bell gets to confirm
that gideon has the darksaber
before the imperial officer bites down
on the star wars version of a cyanide
capsule
bow asks mano to join them but he
rejects this
and instead asks for information on the
jedi this is where we learn of ahsoka
who is in the city of kaladin on the
forest planet of corvis
ahsoka is of course a massive character
in the star wars universe
and it's been long theorized that she
would be appearing in the series at some
point
with these directions mano picks up the
child the frog family
welcome their own child and we end the
episode with the razor looking like a
fishing boat
now before we get into what could be
happening next i just want to remind you
that we do videos like this every day
so if you're enjoying it then please
subscribe to the channel
don't forget we're also giving away
three copies of the marvel phase two box
set
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below
the winners are going to be chosen on
the 30th of november so make sure you
get involved
now going forward mando is heading out
to ahsoka
but as we know from the series nothing
is ever straightforward
and when things are left on a
cliffhanger it can often be a long time
before they're resolved
so who knows if we will actually get to
see ahsoka next episode
and that falling bit of metal left
behind by the ship
does tease to me that it's gonna
encounter some problems before they
arrive at corvus
boba fett is also still out there
looking for mando
and i would actually love to see the
character appear in the next entry
however if things go smoothly and we do
meet ahsoka
then she will likely fill us in with a
lot of information
the clone wars ended with her fate
unknown and though she was in rebels
there's very little that we actually
have concrete about what's happened to
her
she will likely be played by rosario
dawson and
the jedi master will probably take the
child under her wing
and start to provide him with the jedi
training that he needs
now this also leaves the door open for
darth maul who was a big
rival of both beau and ahsoka ray park
was rumored to be in the series
i think it would be incredible if he
popped up either way there's a lot of
directions that they can take it
and i really can't wait to see what
happens obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the episode
so make sure you comment below and let
me know if you enjoyed this video then
please drop a thumbs up
and make sure you check out our
breakdown of who baby oda is which will
be linked at the end
we go over the best theories so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat is under discord
server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i'll be paul i'll
see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
my
just